we finally got around to reviewing the
RX 598 the XFX Fatboy it's got some
thermal problems we'll be talking about
that later but also not a whole lot of
motive to read to review this quickly
because it's a RiRi fresh there's the R
X 480
then the 580 came out it's a refresh of
the 480 it's a pre overclock the 590
came out which is a pre overclocked 580
which is a pre overclocks 480 so it's
it's not that inherently exciting it's
not new architecture it's there's not a
whole lot new going on but it's still
worth reviewing because even though it's
a refresh as we saw with the 580 it
might have a pretty good place in the
market so the 580 despite being a
refresh a pre overclocked one did turn
out to be a decent buy at its price
point and that's what we're gonna look
at today with you or axe 590
specifically the Fatboy model that we
have here and I will talk thermals power
and gaming performance before that this
video is brought to you by coursers
vengeance RGB memory Corsairs vengeance
RGB Ram uses pre-screened ICS for better
overclocking Headroom and tighter
timings courses Ram also has the benefit
of wide region motherboard support by
landing on qualified vendor lists for
motherboard makers and trained wide
compatibility between boards learn more
at the link in the description below for
the specs on this if you want to know
I'm watch our our X 480 review from like
two or three years ago and then watch
the 580 review those are the specs it's
a higher clock so we've got that covered
beyond that pricing is probably the most
relevant thing to notice or for
perspective the 1070 TI cost about 360 -
$450 depend on which model you're buying
when you buy it where you buy it the non
blower models the ones that are actually
worth buying are closer to 430 to 450 us
that's the 1070 TI the 590 the RX 590
costs about $260 for a model similar to
this one I think this is 270 right now
about the same thing no 270 to 60 so
you're looking at 170 dollars more for
performance that well we'll talk about
that later but the 1070 Ti is a
different class of performance not the
best comparison that a better comparison
might be something like
the 1060 or maybe the 1070 and because
the RX 590 does fall between them and
performance in a lot of instances the
pricing should also be between them so
1060 s these days if you haven't looked
the the 1066 Giga Byte the real like the
legitimate one
the original 66 ka not to be confused
with the other five that came out that's
about two hundred ten bucks in the US
for for one of those and they go up to
240 250 so not a ton of price movement
but a bit since it came out and that
puts it a little cheaper than this one
or you get the 1070 for something like
300 plus or minus 20 on average 300 320
so that's where you looking at for the
price stack up so let's go through the
game benchmarks we'll talk about gaming
FPS frame times talking about thermals
power consumption and a bit more for the
XFX
rx 590 fat boy Sniper Elite 4 gives us a
look at a well implemented DirectX 12
title with close to hardware programming
including asynchronous compute support
we'll start with our 4k results as those
are the more complete and give us a good
picture of scalability versus other
hardware remember the idea here is that
we can see how the RX 590 compares
relative to other devices not
necessarily to see absolute performance
well look at other results with lower
resolutions for that angle at 4k using
Sniper Elite as sort of a synthetic test
for low-level api's we see the XFX rx
590 fat boy runs at 43 FPS average one
stock or about 46 FPS average one
overclocked lowest for both results are
good with 1% at 41 fps for the OC and 37
fps for the stock result this is
indicative of fluid frame times
something we'll look at in our frame
time plot next the frame rate isn't
where we want it but again that's all
relative to graphics settings what's
important here is that frame time
consistency is there absolute numbers
will rise with lower settings
momentarily as for the rx 580 the real
one the msi RX 580 gaming x not the data
land card which is a 570
that AMD respawn is a 580 we end up at
39 FPS for the 8 gigabyte gaming X which
is the same as an overclocked rx 570 ie
dat'll and RX 584 clocking the RX 582
1450 5 megahertz gets it to 41 FPS
average roughly tied with the stock rx
590 that's because an RX 590 is an RX
580 but pre overclocked so this all
makes sense
comparatively the gtx 1070 SC ends up at
48 FPS average with the gtx 1066
gigabyte gaming ax at 37 FPS average
just to be clear that's the 1066
gigabyte not to be confused with the
1063 gigabyte with one fewer SM nor the
1065 the gigabyte and most certainly not
the 1066 gigabyte with nine gigabits per
second memory and finally and most
definitely absolutely not the gtx 1060
gddr5 x6 gigabyte card just the gtx 1066
gigabyte nvidia has ensured that all
future mentions of the gtx 760 must be
accompanied by this statement of
clarification the point is the 1060 is
beaten by the 590 which is functionally
an overclocked 580 which wasn't
overclocked to our X 480 the 1060 with
an overclock ends up at 40 FPS average
within striking range of the RX 590 but
still outperformed by 7.8 percent the
gtx 1070 outperforms the stock rx 590 by
about 12% with a 1070 TI at 57 FPS
average or leading by 32% when comparing
only stock to stock the frame time Delta
is about seventeen point six seven
milliseconds bursts of 23 milliseconds
on the 590 so about 5.6 milliseconds
different frame times from the previous
chart looked like this the gtx 1070 drew
the most frames of course and also
managed to keep consistently tight frame
times to the frame to frame interval
variants of plus or minus one
millisecond
this is incredibly good performance and
is commendable of the car remember frame
times are all about consistency of
delivery being lower on the chart is
better but being consistent frame the
frame is best
the 1070 is both but it's also more
expensive drawing the RX 580 line next
we see the frame time plot trends higher
closer to 25 to 30 milliseconds rather
than 18 to 24 of the 1070 frame the
frame consistency is still good with the
frame to frame deviation of plus or
minus 2 milliseconds on average that is
good performance and completely
the RX 590 Fat Boys next now again this
is 4k resolution so what we're looking
at is the consistency of frame delivery
not the outright frame rate the Fat Boy
plots with the line competitive to the
gtx 1070 and frame time consistency its
frame rate is lower and the count of
frames rendered is reduced as we saw in
the previous chart but it's consistency
is reliable this is good because frame
rate can be resolved by reducing graphic
settings but frame time consistency is
difficult to fix the 590 does this well
as do the other cards and so finally
we'll plot the gtx 1066 gigabyte for
perspective we see similarly commendable
frame time consistency but overall
reduced frame rate the higher placement
on the y-axis means that the gtx 1060
runs slower and frame throughput than
the other cards on the chart
despite competitive consistency of those
fewer frames the RX 590 ends up between
the 1066 and the gtx 1070 cards in both
frame rate and frame time performance
and up for k numbers let's look at a
truncated chart with just 1080p we
haven't done as many lower end devices
and sniper so this chart is more limited
in quantity of cars but we'll make up
for that in the next few games these
cards of them the RX 590 leads the gtx
1060 and somewhat meaningfully
outperforms the RX 580 the RX 570
matches the RX 581 overclocked which is
as a reminder what the data land rx 580
represents so if you missed the previous
content the data land rx 580 is an RX
570 it's just AMD called it an RX 580
2048 made a new SKU out of the 570
that's what that card is that's why
there scare quotes so the scare quotes
around the 580 are because it's 570 the
distribution doesn't have too much
spread against these devices but the 590
is in a better position than the other
cards on the chart as before the 1070
would outperform the 590 but the 590
outperforms the 1064 f1 2018 we look at
the counterpart to Sniper Elite 4 by
benchmarking with a prime example of a
well-built DirectX 11 game there are
more API abstraction layers than with
DirectX 12 but this particular game
handles them well at 4k the RX 590 ends
up at 38 FPS average stock roughly
with the overclocked variants 40 FPS
flat the gtx 1070 ends up at 46 FPS
average and the RX 588 gigabyte gaming
ex runs 35.7 FPS average when stock and
38 FPS average wid overclocked the
overclocked result here puts it about on
par with the RX 5 90's stock although
the overclocked 590 again pulls
marginally ahead 1440p is a more
reasonable resolution for the 590 soul
moved to that chart now for case not
really the Forte of the RX 590 at 1440p
and f1 2018 the RX 598 gigabyte card
ends up at 64 FPS average with 1% lows
averaging 47 FPS overclocking didn't do
much for us gaining an additional 3 fps
and the GTX 770 is the next card
somewhat distant ranking at 78 FPS
average and with low similarly paced as
the RX 590 the ARS 590 outperforms the
gtx 1066 gigabyte card when stock
running 57 FPS average and overclocked
running 61 FPS average with the plus 100
core offset for reference to 1066
gigabyte card it costs about $200 to
$250 and depending on the model and the
current sales the RX 598 runs about 260
to 280 depending on model will talk
value more later but that gives you an
idea of where they land it's fully
capable of 1440p though and ranks
between the 1070 1066 gigabyte at 1080p
the RX 590 ends up pushing 82 FPS
average when stock or 85 FPS overclocked
once again overclocking is hardly useful
for this GPU the RX 590 performs about
the same as the RX 580 gaming ex when
it's overclocked to fourteen fifty five
megahertz with both cards averaging 80
FPS the 1060 overclocked is around the
same performance although gains against
the baseline 1060 are noteworthy the
1070 maintains a significant advantage
of the 590 in these charts party at 101
FPS average of the stock version far cry
5 gives us a look at ubisoft dunia
engine pulling the title with more
geometric complexity and screen space
reflections than some other testing
we've gone through so far for this one
the RX 590 Fatboy ends up at 30fps
average with an overclocked pitifully
pushing it to 31.5 FPS so no real gain
the gtx 770 runs at 36 FPS average while
the overclocked 580 gaming ax
i card at 1455 megahertz runs the same
frame rate as the RX 590 since you know
it's an overclocked RX 580 none of these
are particularly playable so let's move
on to 1440p at 1440p with the higher
settings that we're using designated on
the charge satan's become reasonably
playable the RX 590 stock GPU operates
an average frame rate of 55 which is
ahead of an overclocked to 1066 gigabyte
card by about 3.9 percent we're outside
of standard deviation tests to test but
not by much the difference is
imperceptible to the user for a fairer
comparison of stock to stock testing the
gtx 1066 gigabyte stock without an
overclock ends up at 50 FPS average
still within reasonable range of the RX
590 the 590 doesn't hold a stron of an
advantage here as it has in some other
titles the gtx 1070 SCS average frame
rate of 67 FPS post the lead of 21% over
the 590 stock GPU with the 580 roughly
tied with a 10 61% and 0.1% lows are
both well times across all of these
configurations the most important thing
to learn from our multi-resolution
testing as we move into the 1080p chart
is whether performance scales linearly
across all resolutions if it doesn't
that could be indicative of a pipeline
limitation ROPS
for example or maybe video memory or
texture map units at 1080p and far cry 5
the RX 590 maintains similar spacing
against the gtx 960 and 1060 overclocked
cards it's tied with the overclocked to
1060 and leading the stock by about 6.7%
overclocking the RX 590 gets it to 80
FPS average but there's just no more
room left in this card to overclock any
meaningful amount at least not without
mods we see gains from overclocking of
2.4 percent over the stock rx 590 and
finally the 1070 maintains a significant
lead post in a 96 FPS average of the 590
78 FPS average that's also accompanied
by a price increase of course and will
point out that Vega 56 does pretty well
in this title also posting a 104 FPS
average with the power color stock model
the Vega 56 cards average about four
hundred fifty to four hundred seventy
dollars so buyers of the 590 are likely
not willing to stretch this high-end
price shadow of the Tomb Raider is still
relatively
and is meant to be one of the leading
r-tx titles although our benchmark scene
is standardized without any r-tx
features Shadow the Tomb Raider is on a
modified Crystal engine and uses DirectX
12 for its API one note for this one we
had trouble getting the overclocked to
stabilize in this game for the 590 but
eventually got it running at 1650 to
1660 megahertz core rather than 1660 to
1670 and other titles 4k isn't very
friendly to this class of device when
using the settings we were using placing
the RX 590 Fatboy at 28 FPS average with
an overclock doing effectively nothing
the 1070 also struggles down at 30 FPS
average with a 1070 TI at 35 fps so
let's move on right away we can't learn
much here at 1440p the RX 590 ends up at
50 FPS average with the overclock taking
us only 250 1.4 FPS not exciting sadly
and about what we've been seeing thus
far that most high rx 580 gaming that
except 1450 5 megahertz hits 48 fps
average position it itself close enough
to the 590 that the differences are
imperceptible the gtx 1070 holds a 55
FPS average marking shadow of the Tomb
Raider as the title where the RX 590
strikes the closest to the gtx 1070 to
the point that the value for this game
best favors the 590 in terms of
percentages the 1070 holds just the lead
of 8.5% of the 590 which holds a lead of
roughly 11% over the stock 580 and the
overclocked 10 60s around that range to
running 1080p instead the RX 590 ends up
at 72 FPS average which is completely
playable while using high graphics
settings the overclocked is once again
pitiful foods Tina is only at 1.9%
that's disappointing and this really not
much to be gained here because the cards
already a pre overclocked spree
overclocked card so there are X 580 with
an overclocked is again close to the RX
590 stock GPU not that exciting and
predictable but still an improvement of
sorts GTA 5 is last using the rage
engine which is redundant by Rockstar
Games the benchmark is intensive on draw
distance particularly for geometric
detail and shadow detail at long
ranges 4k is almost entirely unplayable
with our very high and ultra mix of
settings on our standardized test bench
and the that's for the rx 590 the iris
590 is positioned with results of about
25 FPS average for the stock 590 Fatboy
or 23 fps for the 580 gaming x stock
let's skip right over to 1440p at 14:40
PG ta positions the RX 590 Fatboy at 51
FPS average tied exactly with the
overclocked
rx 580 gaming X and marginally ahead of
the rx 580 sort of boring if we're being
honest but that's the nature of a reef
refresh if you already knew where the RX
580 landed when stock and overclocked
you could figure out where the RX 590
would be and where it is in this game
the gtx 1060 leads is performance over
the RX 590 if GTA is the only finger
plane and if you can find a 1066
gigabyte for about 200 to 220 dollars
it'd be a better buy for this title
branching out to other games would
change that prioritization and GTA is
pretty old so you also have to question
how long you'd be playing only that game
these results are consistent with other
sites and are a bit unique to GTA 1080p
for GTA gives us our last game test the
RX 590 and gtx 1060 maintain the same
spacing as before with a 1066 gigabyte
card leading the 590 by large margins
marking 83 FPS average stock versus 76
FPS average stock the 1070 polls even
further ahead landing at 106 FPS average
and the overclocked msi RX 580 is about
the same as the 390 X and there rx 590
when the 580 is overclocked power
consumption is last for this we do a
total system power consumption logged
over time so this is not for the
individual card but for the entire test
bench all system components are heavily
controlled with voltages even minor
voltage rails also heavily controlled to
ensure data accuracy the RX 590 stock
GPU total system power consumption
average is about 320 watts with the msi
RX 580 gaming X system averaging 20 to
30 watts lower on average and that's
without having the overclock applied so
that's stock the GTX 1066
by total system power averages 240 watts
when the 1060 is overclocked with a plus
100 megahertz core offset as shown in
previous charts the 590 is still a heavy
drinker of power as the previous rx 500
series cards have been for thermals we
first tested the card with the stock V
BIOS configuration which is with the
switch set toward the PCIe connectors
XFX says this is the faster fan speed v
bios were the more aggressive v bios but
that was clearly inaccurate the GBO core
hits about 79 to 80 degrees Celsius at
steady state which is the temperature
target for this v bios this is the stock
setting under these settings the V Ram
module we measured climbs to a hide
ninety one point eight degrees Celsius
this is nearing the specification limit
of gddr5 and once accounting for
measurement error and the fact that
we're looking at T case naught T
Junction might even be hitting this back
limit it's close enough to be
disquieting the MOSFET we measured is at
85 degrees this is hot and uncompetitive
but is technically well within the
operating temperature specs for MOSFETs
most FETs can take 125 to 150 degrees
Celsius so we're not in any danger here
it's just not competitive with other
coolers and is indicative of inefficient
design and use of an otherwise large
cooler it's just it's not efficient for
how big it is fan speed for this V bios
hits around 1,500 rpm to maintain eighty
degrees on the GPU but the trouble is
that the neighboring components run hot
with the left v bios switch engaged
instead not the stock position the GPU
core runs 69 to 70 degrees Celsius with
the vram now at 81 degrees
definitely more acceptable and the
mosfet at 74 degrees considering fan
speed is now 2,000 rpm up from 1492 1500
this remains uncompetitive with others
on the market but is more acceptable
than the stock measurements you'll want
to switch into this mode for normal use
especially if in a hotter case and one
that might push ambient temperature is
higher than the 22 plus or minus 1
degrees that we test in and just as a
reminder we pointed all of this out when
we did the teardown of the rx 590 it was
a while ago but we'll cut to some
footage of it just as a reminder instead
of using
a copper coal plate contacts and
everything or even an aluminum one
they're using a steel cold plate
contacting the vram and that's connected
via screws then connected to the rest of
the cooler so it would have made more
sense to do some kind of direct contact
even with just just pads or paste or
something between the vram and the heat
pipes or whatever's there ideally you go
with a larger single plate that covers
the GPU in the vram or one that maybe
has stepped down for the GPU for
clearance purposes but with a design
that was chosen where it's it's multiple
connecting interfaces you lose
efficiency every time you transfer heat
through a new interface and there are a
lot of them here for this card so it is
inefficient and it runs hot for the vram
as a result this is something that we we
warned about when we tore the card apart
but now it's more evident that it is a
problem conclusively then the rx 590 is
boring doesn't mean it's bad it doesn't
mean it doesn't have a place in the
market but it is genuinely a boring
products who work on or review now
that's okay because in terms of price to
performance it does find is it's the
same as by it's almost literally the
same as buying an RF 580 and an
overclocked unit so obviously there's no
reason to upgrade if you have a 40 or
582 this if you don't have one of those
you could buy the rx 590 if it's at 260
270 dollars a gigabyte model and
performance is pretty good actually it's
really not bad frame times were
consistent overall there were no major
problems with frame times we did not
have major problems with drivers a lot
of those seem to have been fixed lately
with a and these efforts they're
overclocking extremely uninteresting
we'd recommend and said something like
Vega 56 it's significantly more
expensive to go that route but if you
want something for overclocking for fun
like that's why you're buying it not
just for gaming then don't bother
don't buy this for that Vega d6 is good
for that route if you prefer to go that
route and stay AMD and honestly 56 is a
bit more fun to work with for
overclocking than Nvidia anyway you have
more freedom with it but as a card out
of
box it's fine it's just it's not
exciting it is a fair replacement for
the 1060 if you're looking at 10 60s as
one of your options right now and you
can't find them maybe in your region for
the prices we have here like 210 bucks
then this is superior at the same price
for sure it's in some games superior at
higher prices because it's never really
more than 40 $50 more and depending on
the game workload you're looking at the
590 does better enough that it's worth
buying there are instances where that's
not true
GTA 5 and this is consistent another
test we've looked at GTA 5 specifically
does favor the 1060 over even the 590 so
if that's the only game you're playing
then don't bother but otherwise you're
playing more things it seems fine 1070
you get I don't know anywhere from 7 to
12% more performance on average there
are a couple games where that's wait
less just depends on the title but 7 to
12% more performance looking at like $40
more for the low-end 1070 is 50 60 for
the mid-range ones so I probably is just
it's really granular right now and video
has 18 billion skews of Pascal cards and
Andy isn't intending to compete with
just as many of Polaris cards so you end
up with a product stack we're telling
you which one to buy is very much going
game by game cart by card and saying get
this one for this game get this one for
that game and so all I can say is look
at the charts and I can tell you that
this specific model probably not one we
recommend necessarily the the thermal
performance is a joke a la Thea I mean
in one of those tests thermals were
hitting like 90 degrees Celsius on some
of the power components which is
technically within spec but if you're
gonna make a card this literally named
the Fat Boy and being bigger than two
slots make it cool so we don't recommend
this specific model the 590 as a product
itself seems fair it's fine but get a
different one this one is just the
cooling is just no so that's it for this
one
subscribe for more as always and get a
store like here his exes that night to
help us out directly hopefully we'll
have some more exciting GPUs coming from
AMD at some point in the future and as
soon as we do we'll review those as well
let you know how they do I'll see you
all next time
[Music]